You shot this in Los Angeles.
I'm curious, Joel, you're riding around in a squad car,
and you are dressed as this alien creature,
this Orc-like creature.
You're wearing ...
Can we see actually what you were wearing?
You were wearing a ton of makeup. And ...
[Will] Whoa
[Conan] First of all, what was that makeup like for you?
[Joel] Well, first of all, it was important that you cover
this face. You know what I mean?
(Will laughs)
Why? It looks so much like my face.
(crowd laughs)
Why would you want to cover it?
What I wanted to say was that it was important to cover
your face, but uh ...
(crowd laughs)
Right, no, see?
I had that coming, I had that coming.
But that looks like it's pounds of makeup.
It's three and a half hour or three ...
Chris, who won an Oscar just immediately after we finished
for Suicide Squad, was my makeup artist, and it was ...
We got it down to like three hours.
But what's interesting is running around with this fella.
[Will] Yeah.
Naw, I mean it was, it's like he was being really modest.
It was a mess. It's three-quarters of an inch of-
[Chris] He was losing his mind.
He was losing his mind.
[Chris] I would be talking to him, giving him direction,
and sweat is just squirting out of his ears.
[Joel] Yeah, yeah. I'm back now though.
I'm back now and I'm fine.
You had a nickname for the makeup it was so heavy.
The couch.
The couch, yeah.
The couch. 'Cause it's fun,
but what's interesting is the power of this fellow
because like you're driving around,
and like I'm a monster driving a car,
and there's a bunch of people downtown who were watching
both of us riding in a squad car down, you know,
one of the boulevards down there, and then I'm like, yeah,
there's a monster driving the car, but, "Hey Will, Will!"
(crowd laughs)
You see monsters everyday,
but it's not everyday you see Will Smith.